bonjour nous sommes en direct ce
vendredi matin pour vous faire un
nouveau point sur la guerre en Ukraine
une guerre qui dure maintenant depuis
presque un an ça fait débuter en février
vous le savez ils ont fou fait
régulièrement des points de situation
sur ce conflit avec Alexis ferchak
bonjour Alexis bonjour Vincent on va
parler avec vous de tout ce qui s'est
passé ces derniers semaines ces derniers
ces derniers mois non c'est plutôt ces
dernières semaines puisque il y a quand
même du mouvement peut-être parler
d'abord d'un point de vue général avec
cette carte le conflit globalement ne
bouge plus beaucoup oui alors j'ai
encore me répéter mais si on prend une
carte extrêmement dézoomée de la guerre
c'est à peu près la même carte que que
la dernière qu'on avait vu à une
différence près mais qui s'observe pas
réellement sur certaines cartes-ci c'est
qu'il y a une bataille extrêmement
violente qui a lieu encore juste au nord
à quelques kilomètres de la ville de bac
mouth qu'on voit écrit en blanc dans du
dans du bleu on est là vraiment dans
du Dombas alors pour le dire très vite
les Russes ont annexé officiellement
quatre Oblats de région à l'ouest vous
voyez il y a le Blas de Carson qui qui
traversait par le Nieppe là il n'y a
plus de combat pourquoi parce que les
Russes se sont retirés c'est la zone en
bleu de de la rive droite d'une Nièvre
on se souvient c'était il y a à peu près
un mois et demi maintenant et donc
maintenant il y a le niap qui est
extrêmement large qui sépare les deux
belligérants ensuite on passe à l'est il
y a le blast de zapuridja et là pour
l'instant le front est relativement
calme on en reparlera tout à l'heure les
deux belligérants sont vraiment
l'infaste à l'autre il y a des tiers
d'artillerie mais ils sont on va dire
fortifiés dans leur position ensuite si
on remonte il y a le Blas de donièsk qui
aujourd'hui vraiment focalise toutes les
attentions la ville de bac mout
typiquement et la base de donnéesk et
puis si on remonte encore au nord il y a
le Blas de Lougansk alors ça c'est
intéressant parce que il y avait vous
voyez il y avait une autre
contre-offensive ukrainienne on va dire
en septembre octobre qui était celle
dans la région de kerkiff tous les
territoires en bleu ont été libérés par
les Ukrainiens les Russes étaient malgré
tout pas mal avancé on voit notamment la
ville d'izum qui auparavant était prise
par les Russes aujourd'hui elle est
ukrainienne et donc il y a cette poussée
ukrainienne que les Russes pour
l'instant ont réussi à arrêter ils se
sont ils ont fortifiés leurs positions
et même depuis quelques semaines depuis
quelques semaines il y a le pendant le
dernier mois ils ont regrapillé un tout
petit peu de territoire sur les iconiens
c'est très faible ça s'observe pas
forcément énormément sur cette carte
mais là il y a vraiment une ligne de
front qui est marquée et on va dire
relativement stable non pas au sens où
il y a pas de combat mais par rapport au
combat qui se déroule dans le donatsk et
notamment autour de backmouth rien à
voir en termes d'intensité les combats
les plus intenses c'est donc
abaquemouth et notamment au nord de
backmouth à Solena et c'est le principal
enfin objet à mon avis de notre émission
aujourd'hui effectivement on va en
parler je salue déjà tous les autres qui
nous qui nous rejoignent VLF qui est
infidèle et qui est heureux de nous
retrouver nous aussi on est heureux de
retrouver Machiavel ricochet
Joe cost qui est avec nous souvent Chris
Koon vous n'hésitez pas bien sûr à poser
vos questions on essaie d'y répondre
comme d'habitude on va du coup se
pencher sur la situation de bac mood et
Solidar avec cette carte voilà c'est
cette carte donc là on a zoomé sur le
petit point où il y avait marqué
backmouth
backmoona là on est dans l'aublast de
denisk et dans cette aubelas il y a donc
ces forces russes et c'est fort
sucriniennes qui se font face absolument
alors déjà là on voit bien que la ville
de backgroute est plus grande que la
ville de soléda donc la bataille qui se
déroule actuellement pour solidaire qui
est juste au nord il y a vraiment
quelques kilomètres entre les deux c'est
quasiment rien
donc ce Léa avant guerre aujourd'hui il
y a quasiment plus de civil c'est une
ville complètement détruite on va en
parler mais avant-guerre c'était une
ville de 12000 habitants c'est pas non
plus gigantesque alors les Russes et les
Ukrainiens ne disent pas la même chose
et même les rues sont entre eux ne
disent pas la même chose pourquoi la
bataille est menée principalement et
même quasiment très très grande partie
non pas par l'armée russe mais par
Wagner donc les mercenaires de Wagner ce
groupe militaire privé qui donc à la
salle de la Russie à la seule de la
Russie c'est pris goji le cuisinier de
Poutine qui a un rôle de plus en plus
important
au sein des des élites et donc ce sont
ces hommes qui mènent principalement les
combats à background solida la bataille
de backmouth elle est menée depuis des
mois et des mois et des mois et les
avancées se faisaient chaque jour
c'était peut-être quelques
c'était quasiment on pouvait peut-être
très difficile de tenir à jour une carte
et là on va dire c'est dix derniers
jours il y a eu une poussée russe non
pas à backmouthman mais à soleda là il y
a aucun doute là-dessus les
Ukrainiens ont reculé largement en
quelques jours on voit la zone orange
foncée ça correspond à ce que les à ce
que les les Russes sont pris et je
dirais même parce que le problème c'est
que les informations elles sont très
difficiles à voir donc ça c'est une
carte on va dire conservatrice entre
guillemets alors les Russes et les
Ukrainiens n'ont Dispa la même chose dès
jeudi Wagner donc trilogie a annoncé sur
telegram que la ville de soleda avait
été prise par ses forces le ministère de
russe de la Défense a démenti ce qui est
intéressant c'est que le ministère russe
de la Défense n'a pas parlé des troubles
de Wagner ils ont parlé des troupes des
VDV c'est des troupes aéroportés donc
deux au sein des armées russes et donc
ça monte bien la rivalité qui existe
entre
le ministère de la défense de
schweighoux et Prigogine les
Ukrainiens eux ne reconnaissent pas la
prise de Solidar par les Russes il
disent qu'il résiste alors où on est
exactement la situation
moi j'ai essayé de regarder avec des des
sources ouvertes et notamment l'analyse
que certains chercheurs font des réseaux
sociaux donc il y a des vidéos des
images etc et on essaie de les
géolocaliser pour estimer quel
territoire est pris par un tel ou par un
tel ce qui semble la propressure c'est
que tout soulédard c'est une zone grise
et que les Russes contrôlent à peu près
la grande majorité de la ville au moins
l'Est et le Sud et qu'il y a encore une
présidence ukrainienne forte et une
ligne une vraie ligne de front à l'Ouest
notamment près de la et il y a beaucoup
de mines de sel solidares l'étymologie
vient de là et donc il y a notamment une
mine de sel qui est toujours tenue par
les Ukrainiens tout ça c'est quand même
du conditionnel et ça peut évoluer très
rapidement les Ukrainiens par exemple ce
matin même ont annoncé une contrepensive
on n'en sait rien des deux côtés il y a
de la propagande de guerre donc faut
être extrêmement prudent ce qui est
certain c'est que le rapport de force
actuellement est en faveur des Russes
dans cette ville après qu'est-ce qu'il
en sera dans quelques jours on ne sait
pas exactement et donc voilà faut rester
présent alors une question de Marc Léon
puisque vous la disiez c'est Solidar
c'est une fille qui est connue
mais de se concentrer après c'est connu
pour ses mines de selles là-bas qui nous
parle de réseaux souterrains absolument
est-ce qu'il y aurait des tunnels qui
pourraient amener alors on a une
question de Marc ayant qui demande
est-ce qu'il y aurait des tunnels qui
pourraient amener derrière les lignes
on a beaucoup vu ça sur les réseaux
sociaux ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il y a
des réseaux de tunnels donc c'est à dire
qu'il y a peut-être encore des forces
ukrainiennes qui résistent dans ces
tunnels on avait vu ça Mario Paul
c'était pas une mine de scène c'était
une série
mais ça c'est certain il y a la
problématique des dépôts d'armes
c'est un des enjeux c'est pour ça qu'on
peut pas dire actuellement
exactement où on en est on parle
effectivement d'une mine de sel à
l'ouest de Solidar et qui descendrait
pas mal au sud de vers krasnaora qui est
le la localité entre backmouth et
Solidar ça sert à rien de rentrer trop
dans les détails il faut attendre
quelques jours pour voir ce qu'il en est
mais vous avez fait une remarque
intéressante en disant bah Solidar avant
personne ne connaissait en revanche si
on disait un français il y a quasiment
un an de cela maintenant
Kef il connaissait et ça montre quelque
chose qui est à mon avis l'un des deux
points Ess il faut retenir aujourd'hui
c'est la diminution non pas de
l'intensité mais une réduction de
l'échelle géographique des combats
depuis un an ce qui montre alors ce que
je veux dire c'est qu'au départ
l'invasion commence le 24 février en
gros on va passer sur la sur la carte
générale sur cette carte en gros les
rues s'attaquer de tous les côtés
par le nord ils ont même essayé de
prendre en tenaille la ville de Kiev
donc au départ c'était cette échelle de
cette échelle là dont on parlait
l'échelle de l'ensemble de l'Ukraine
ensuite très rapidement en réalité dès
le 31 mars 1er avril il y a eu un
basculement les Russes ont été obligés
de se replier de Kiev et les objectifs
du Kremlin à partir de là en tout cas
officiellement c'était la bataille du
Dombas c'était alors le Dombas c'est une
région historique qui est composée des
deux oplas de lugank et de Niass donc
parler tout à l'heure et donc on voit
que les Russes contrôlent la
quasi-totalité Lougansk et en revanche
il leur manque à peu près 40% de de
données donc ça devenait la nouvelle
échelle au niveau opératif des des
combats et donc là on le voit pas sur la
carte vous voyez bakkout mais à l'ouest
de bakkmouth
il y a deux grandes villes mais vraiment
pas très loin disons à 20 km il y a deux
grandes villes qui s'appellent
créateurs et la viande et cramator ce
qui est la capitale
ukrainienne du douniaque de l'aublas de
nièce depuis que la ville de Donetsk
plus au sud qu'on voit sur la carte a
été prise mais dès 2014 par les Russes
et donc est devenu donc il fallait
changer de capital donc maintenant
l'objectif stratégique des Russes en
tout cas l'un de ceux des objectifs en
tout cas l'objectif affiché c'est de
prendre l'intégralité du Denis pour
avoir tout le bon masque et donc pour ça
il faut qu'il prenne qu'un matosk et
donc là on voit avec le bleu et le
orange quel est quel était la manœuvre
heureuse c'était une manœuvre russe dans
cercle monde d'enveloppement par le nord
on voit la isium pour prendre les
Ukrainiens en sandwich une sorte de
tenaille
et ensuite récupérer le Dombas alors
sauf que ça ça n'a pas marché les Russes
n'ont pas réussi et donc maintenant
l'échelle des combats s'est réduite de
nouveau ces derniers mois et on parlait
de la ville de bac mouth qui a indiqué
sur la carte bac mood 80 000 habitants
pourquoi parce que backmouth c'est la
dernière ligne offensive va défensive
ukrainienne avant créateur fixe la
viande et alors maintenant on parle même
plus de de backmouth on parle de soledar
qui a quelques kilomètres au nord de
pakmouth pourquoi parce que Solidar
pourrait permettre ensuite dans un
deuxième temps heureuse de prendre
darkmouth qui ensuite une fois qu'ils
auraient pris peut-être prendre un
batteur
et ça il faut le le répéter absolument
parce que quand on parle de la guerre il
faut avoir vraiment une
consciente de cette réduction de
l'échelle géographique des combats
une fois qu'on a dit ça il y a un billet
une illusion d'optique à ne pas avoir
enfin
contourner c'est que
les réflexions en termes de kilomètres
carrés occupés c'est pas la seule
variable pertinente
notamment parce que pendant ce temps-là
l'intensité des combats elle ne s'est
pas réduite et peut-être même qu'elle a
augmenté
depuis plusieurs mois et on le verra
elle est appelée à augmenter encore
pourquoi parce que les deux camps
essaient de se renforcer se mobilise et
il faut bien avoir conscience là c'est
en termes de kilomètres carrés mais on
va dire en densité de troupes
au sol les forces à la fois russe et
ukrainiennes sont concentrés très
largement dans la région du don-basse et
donc là c'est une autre dimension de la
guerre c'est ce qu'on appelle l'usure on
a on nous en parle justement on en
anglais on parle d'être ici et le nom a
été transféré
si oui qui peut la gagner mais ça fait
longtemps voilà
je vous disais que les cartes étaient
problème c'est vrai que ça fait 6 mois
qu'on prend la grande carte on n'a pas
l'impression d'énormes changements à
part quand même malgré tout les deux
grands mouvements
Ukrainiens
à la fois Carson au sud et à carquif au
nord mais en revanche il y a une dans
tout l'argument du bas
on voit pas de grandes de grandes
manœuvre mais donc là il faut bien il
faut bien avoir à l'esprit que abaque
moods qui se joue en termes d'intensité
des combats c'est absolument
colossal c'est un délivre de feu
surtout du côté russe parce que les
Russes ont une masse en termes
d'artillerie que les Ukrainiens n'ont
pas et qu'ils essaient de compenser par
une une précision des frappes
supérieures et donc voilà donc la guerre
d'usure c'est il y a deux masques qui se
font face
et donc c'est à qui tiendra le plus
longtemps et donc c'est
quelle perte d'un côté par rapport à
l'autre et combien de temps on peut
tenir on est exactement là dedans alors
je lisais un article de Wall Street
Journal ou du Washington je sais plus
qui dit que par exemple à soledar les
pères des deux côtés sont absolument
considérables en termes d'usure il y a
un léger avantage à la Russie
c'est-à-dire que les en tout cas soleda
les troupes ukrainiennes
ont une adression supérieure à celle des
Russes mais il peut y avoir un effet
domino si donc il faut pas simplement se
dire
Solidar c'est dix mille habitants la
ligne de front est figée très largement
figée depuis plusieurs mois donc la
guerre en Ukraine a baissé l'intensité
non c'est pas le cas et on va voir que
la question de la mobilisation des deux
côtés tant plutôt à croire que les
prochains mois vont voir une
augmentation de la violence sur le
terrain alors on a une question
justement qui nous demande la demande
ukrainienne de char est-elle une optique
offensive ou défensive face à les 28
titres d'offensives russes alors c'est
qu'on parle des chars c'est très voilà
déjà donc en fait si vous voulez les
Occidentaux ont déjà fourni des chats à
l'Ukraine par le passé même en quantité
pas négligeable mais c'était des chats
d'origine soviétique des T72 voire même
l'été 55 modernisé
venant de pays qui était anciennement
dans le bloc soviétique et qui avait
conservé ces chats et donc les
Ukrainiens savent déjà les utiliser
puisque c'est ce qui constitue la
majeure partie de leur force et donc ces
chats ont déjà été envoyés il y avait un
grand supplémentaire c'était d'envoyer
des chars littéralement occidentaux
et donc là il y a eu une étape de de
franchi puisque les Polonais ont annoncé
qu'ils étaient prêts à fournir une
compagnie de Charles léopard on est char
allemand alors une compagnie Charles
léopard c'est c'est une quinzaine de
chats on est d'accord pour dire que 15
chats ça ne va pas le cours de la guerre
les Russes ont perdu je crois plus de
1500 chats
identifiés c'est-à-dire ça peut être
beaucoup plus il y a des photos etc
peut-être que c'est peut-être que c'est
plus il y a il y a l'amiral blégeant
donc et le directeur de cabinet de
l'État majeur de l'Union européenne à
estimé que les Russes avaient perdu 60%
de leur charte de combat c'est un
chiffre qu'on qu'on retrouve pas
forcément dans d'autres sources par
exemple le chef du Renseignement
estonien il n'y a pas très longtemps
estimé que les Russes avaient un
potentiel de chat encore très important
pourquoi parce que est-ce que on parle
des chats opérationnels ou des chars de
réserves et les Russes ont des milliers
de de chats en réserve c'est-à-dire
qu'ils sont tous opérationnels mais avec
tous ces chars de réserve en quelques
semaines moi on peut arriver
constituer
une nouvelle force et c'est un des
enjeux voilà en tout cas donc les les
Occidentaux sont semblent prêts à
franchir le pas le problème c'est qu'on
parle principalement des chats allemands
léopards que les Allemands sont très
précautionneux dans leur approche et ils
ont clairement pas très envie de fournir
de l'armement lourd aux
Ukrainiens on va voir quel est le
rapport de force
diplomatique mais il est probable qu'on
aille dans les prochains mois
vers
l'approvisionnement de l'Ukraine avec
des chars donc léopard les Leclerc
français c'est peu probable déjà parce
qu'on a très peu on en a 200
opérationnels un peu plus en réserve ils
sont complexes à utiliser donc c'est
pour ça que l'option privilégiée c'est
les Léopards quant au Abrahams
américains là aussi ils sont très
compliqués à déployer donc voilà
néanmoins ce qu'il faut garder à
l'esprit c'est qu'une fois qu'on a
fourni des chars il faut former
les équipages et donc si vous voulez
avant qu'on ait des brigades de
charléopard en Ukraine il faut compter
c'est ce qu'on pense même c'est ce qu'on
ne plus probablement en moi en tout cas
pour qu'il y ait une masse suffisante
qui puisse compter sur le champ de la
taille alors juste pour répondre à la
question offensif défensif
on voit vaguement ce qu'on veut dire
offensif c'est une arme on les a enfin
on prend du territoire on se défend
comme une sorte de bouclier alors que
l'arme offensive c'est une sorte de
d'épée donc on voit un char on se dit
oui ça le le chat c'est pour aller de
l'avant malgré tout il y a quand même
quelque chose qu'il faut pas oublier
c'est que l'Ukraine c'est l'Ukraine qui
s'est fait envahir et c'est la Russie
qui envahit l'Ukraine donc à partir de
ce moment-là n'importe quel opération
ukrainienne est une opération
défensive dans la mesure où l'Ukraine ne
fait qu'essayer de reconquérir les
territoires que la Russie après on a
Machiavel qui nous demande quelle est la
plus grande ville encore tenue par les
Russes actuellement or les villes du 24
qu'ils avaient avant le 24 février alors
dans les commentaires pour moi c'est
Mario Paul 400 000 habitants
mais en réalité
personne n'était plus petit que Mario
Paul d'accord simplement ça avait un
statut de Capital régional ce qui fait
que symboliquement c'était très
important mais je suis quasiment
absolument absolument sûr que c'est
Mario Paul
et effectivement les villes d'avant
enfin prise avant
2022 donc concrètement 2014 il y a des
villes plus grandes c'est deniès
Lougansk et certaines villes de Crimée
comme Sébastopol deniège veut pas dire
du bêtises mais pour moi
c'est à peu près un million d'habitants
je peux pas être voilà mais les ordres
de grandeur c'est ça alors on a VLF qui
nous demande pourquoi ne pas livrer tout
ce dont l'Ukraine a besoin la Russie ne
peut que menacer alors pourquoi cette
retenue de l'Occident pour ne pas
permettre d'ukrainien de prendre le
dessus une bonne fois pour toute
c'est une c'est une excellente question
il y a un enjeu logistique c'est que de
former les gens ça produite
que ça de dire qu'on va créer ça on
n'est pas dans un jeu vidéo vous pouvez
vous expliquer ça déjà c'est l'aspect
purement militaire je dirais
probablement pas l'essentiel l'essentiel
est ailleurs c'est c'est diplomatique je
pense que les
Occidentaux
veulent malgré tout éviter une escalade
incontrôlée
avec la Russie une escalade on la voit
depuis depuis le début elle est là et ne
serait-ce que si on regarde les
équipements qui ont été apportés au
début c'était de l'armement plutôt léger
ensuite on a vu arriver les highmars
c'est l'ange Rocket multiples qui ont
une distance de 80 km qu'on c'est pas un
Game changer parce qu'il y a pas d'armes
magiques mais enfin ça a quand même été
très important pour les pour les
Ukrainiens ensuite on a parlé de blindé
léger vous savez il y a eu tout ce
moment où la fin
les Français ont annoncé des chars
légers 10 RC alors il y a toute une
toute un débat pour savoir est-ce que ce
sont vraiment des chats la réalité c'est
que ce débat sert pas à grand chose le
fait que la France est utilisé le terme
de chat c'était une manière aussi pour
faire pression sur l'Allemagne pour que
justement la question des chats de
combat principal
soit mis sur sur la table et qu'on passe
à la vitesse supérieure voilà la vitesse
supérieure il y aura à mon avis une
question qui va se poser dans les mois à
venir surtout si elle offensive russe
surtout si les Russes
retrouvent une capacité de manœuvre ça
va être les armes à longue portée donc
les à longue portée en tout cas porter
moyenne ou intermédiaire c'était avec
des portées de plus de 100 km 200 300 km
ce qui pourrait déstabiliser la ligne de
front russe en profondeur et là
notamment on pense à une chose c'est que
dans le je parlais tout à l'heure il y a
la fois des des obusidés plus ou moins
complexe on va dire jusqu'à 80 km de
portée et on peut aussi monter un
missile dedans qui est le missile
attaquems et qui lui a une portée 300 km
et pour l'instant les Américains ont
toujours dit on ne livre pas c'est
missiles parce qu'on ne veut pas que les
armes confondissent confondues
servent à taper le territoire russe non
territoire criméen à la rigueur parce
que oui on ne reconnaît pas la
souveraineté de la Russie en Crimée en
tout cas pas au-delà ou quand c'est le
cas il y a pas de de reconnaissance
officielle il y a eu plein de frappes
on a l'impression qu'il y en a de plus
en plus enfin
stratégie maintenant de dire regardez
nous aussi on peut frapper chez vous on
peut frapper loin chez vous est-ce que
c'est absolument
alors pour l'instant l'intensité de ces
frappes ne va pas changer le cours de la
guerre mais disons que c'est quand même
[Musique]
pour la Russie
une sacrée humiliation
par exemple il y avait un aéroport dont
j'ai oublié le nom enfin qui était entre
Moscou et l'Ukraine on va dire donc à
plusieurs centaines de kilomètres je
crois 700 km
c'était pas n'importe quel aéroport
c'était une base aérienne stratégique au
sens où c'est une base aérienne où était
déployée des bombardiers stratégiques
type ti95 t860 qui sont les appareils
dédiés à la dissuasion nucléaire donc
c'était une une frappe je crois que
c'est les robots
je crois que c'est ça et donc du coup ça
a une portée symbolique qui est
évidemment très très élevé
on avait une autre question du coup
parce que
tout à l'heure de cette il y a une
escalade mais il faut qu'elle reste
contrôlée
chriscount devant une situation conflit
si les Russes se voient acculé à un
moment donné futur dans le futur il
risque d'employé des risque-t-il
d'employer des armes nucléaires
tactiques ou d'autres types d'armes
similaires alors je me suis en avais
beaucoup cette discussion les précédents
live alors même que la situation était
beaucoup plus difficile en septembre
octobre pour les Russes puisque il y
avait la contre-offensive ukrainienne à
carquif il y avait le retrait très
difficile des trous bruts de la rive
droite de Carson à ce moment là on était
vraiment dans un moment
où on s'était dit il y aura-t-il un
effondrement au moins local des
troupeaux là il y avait une vraie
inquiétude sur la question de des armes
nucléaires ce que la plupart des
chercheurs disent c'est que pour
l'instant
il y a eu une maîtrise de la de la
grammaire de la dysphasion nucléaire des
deux côtés du côté des Occidentaux du
côté des Russes il y a pas eu de
changement de la doctrine russe en la
matière
Poutine n'a jamais ouvertement menacé
l'Occident de frappe nucléaire il n'a
fait que rappeler la doctrine russe qui
est qui est connu donc de ce point de
vue là je pense que le risque est
maîtrisé de tant que sur le terrain on
l'a vu les rues sont moins en difficulté
qui a quelques mois pourquoi parce que
il y a eu la mobilisation de 300 000
hommes
et que pour l'instant il n'y a pas
depuis Septembre Octobre de nouvelles
contre-offensives
ukrainiennes donc qu'est-ce qu'il en
sera dans les prochains mois on va voir
qu'il y a énormément d'inconnus alors il
y a une arme justement qui me dit
peut-on parler d'un changement
d'équilibre des forces au profit de la
Russie depuis début janvier
le problème c'est que le rapport de
force est difficile à estimer de depuis
le début les grands ordres de grandeur
déjà il faut avoir à l'esprit que la
Russie attaquée avec 150 et 200000
hommes au départ
ce qui était franchement peu pour
s'attaquer un pays comme l'Ukraine qui
est plus grand que la France par le
km². et ça c'était pour le moment la
première heure première erreur
stratégique de Vladimir Poutine dans le
dans le plan de l'opération militaire
spécial ce qui est sûr c'est très
rapidement les Ukrainiens se sont
mobilisés et donc le rapport de force
numérique est passé en faveur des des
Ukrainiens et aujourd'hui on estime
qu'il y a 700 000 Ukrainiens à peu près
à la louche combien il y a de Russes
on va dire qu'il y en a
quelque part entre 300 000 et 500 000 on
dire 400 000 pourquoi parce qu'il y a eu
justement ces 300 000 mobilisés disons
entre 400
et 500 sachant qu'en revanche en termes
d'équipement et là encore de masse les
Russes ont un avantage certain sur les
Ukrainiens on sait que les Russes tirent
entre 10000 et 50000 obus par jour c'est
absolument
considérable maintenant qu'est-ce qui va
se passer dans les prochains mois en
termes d'équipements
il y a cette il y a ces équipements
occidentaux qui vont arriver en Ukraine
dont on a déjà parlé
l'Ukraine va continuer à mobiliser je
crois on est à sa 9e vague de
mobilisation et de l'autre côté la
principale inconnue c'est est-ce que les
Russes on reste au format actuel c'est à
dire l'armée de base donc a été
largement réduite du fait des pertes
plus les 300 000 hommes mobilisés plus
les troubles de Wagner qui sont pas
négligeables on parle de 50 000 50000 et
100.000 hommes notamment fourni par les
prisonniers puisque privilégiés et allé
dans les prisons aussi et elle a dit aux
gens de prison
risqué mais mais malgré tout ça
représente des milliers des milliers
d'hommes
donc est-ce qu'on reste à ce format là
dont on commence à voir les effets sur
le terrain c'est la consolidation
notamment du front à slaviance et
asaporigia n'est pas étranger à cette
mobilisation même si pour l'instant les
300000 hommes n'ont pas été envoyé sur
la ligne de front on parle de 150000
hommes donc à 150 000 hommes
probablement quelque part en réserve et
l'une des questions va être
où est-ce que ce surplus d'homme va être
affecté dans les prochaines semaines par
les Russes
mais la grande question c'est va-t-il y
avoir une nouvelle vague de mobilisation
en Russie
et notamment c'est ce que croient les
Ukrainiens sortis dans la presse
anglo-saxonne les Ukrainiens pensent
qu'il y aura 500 000 soldats russes
mobilisés supplémentaires et donc là on
passera on passera un format d'armée
quand même très super on serait de 400
500 000 à peut-être un peu moins d'un
million et donc c'est pour ça que de
faire de la prospective en n'ayant pas
ces données sur la table c'est
extrêmement compliqué parce que la
Russie ne fera pas la même chose si elle
reste un format de 400000 hommes aussi
il passe un format d'un million
forcément de 800000 est-ce que ricochet
du monde que ça que savons-nous des
objectifs militaires russes en 2023
est-ce que c'est récupéré les
territoires annexés ou la conquête
entière de l'Ukraine est-ce que parce
que depuis le début
conquête on tient de l'Ukraine peut-être
que c'est un objectif dans la tête de
venir petit non c'est rien ça paraît
absolument irréaliste
je vois pas déjà pour une raison je vois
pas comment les Russes maintenant
peuvent franchir le Nièvre puisque la
seule raison pour laquelle les Russes
pouvaient vouloir rester sur la rive
droite d'une Nièvre à Carson
c'était justement pour
pour avoir une tête de pont qui aurait
permis
je défends une tête de pont ce qui est
très coûteux tellement terme logistique
ça n'est pas grand intérêt militaire
sauf à vouloir aller vers l'ouest mais
les Russes n'ont pas les moyens alors
maintenant il y a quand même la question
d'une offensive par la Biélorussie
dont on parle énormément depuis
plusieurs semaines oui qui est de quel
pays qui est au-dessus de l'Ukraine et
par lequel le le
enfin l'armée
le 24 février c'est pas un front par le
nord ils avaient descendu le Nieppe
parler de rive à tchernie et en gros
tchernoby
maintenant la question c'est est-ce que
les Russes ont vraiment les moyens
d'ouvrir un nouveau front soit pour
recommencer une prise de Kiev en passant
par Giannis soit on attaquant beaucoup
plus à l'ouest pour essayer
de couper les routes d'approvisionnement
occidental vers l'Ukraine
ça paraît un peu fou après
les rues sont montrées par le passé qui
pouvaient parfois faire des choses qui
paraissaient un peu excessive donc c'est
à dire qui montrerait qu'il y aura une
sorte de déconnexion entre les objectifs
politiques du Kremlin et la réalité de
des moyens militaires la bilorifie qui
entre en guerre c'est une possibilité
c'est un allié de Vladimir Poutine et
depuis deux trois ans Lucas schenko n'a
plus la marge de manœuvre il avait
auparavant par rapport à la à la Russie
donc aujourd'hui les pieds pieds point
liés quand même au Kremlin malgré tout
la le régime biéloruss c'est très
fragile depuis la réélection contestée
de Lucas and Co et par ailleurs l'armée
Biélorussie probablement
assez faible donc quel sera le risque
politique serait considérable d'envoyer
50000 soldats biélorusses pour quel
impact militaire
à ce stade la plupart des chercheurs
disent que c'est pas l'option la plus
probable on ne peut pas malgré tout
l'exclure
voilà mais c'est vraiment la question y
a-t-il une offensive russe en
préparation avec quelle format d'armée
est-ce qu'on se limite ou 400 000 hommes
de la mobilisation est-ce qu'il y en a
une autre et puis si offensive russe
est-ce que c'est une offensive limitée
dans le don-basse pour retrouver une
capacité de manœuvre est terminée cet
objectif du Kremlin qui pour le coup est
officiel de prendre l'intégralité des
territoires annexés donc tout le don
basse notamment où est-ce que il y a
quelque chose de plus ambitieux que ça
soit par Kiev que ce soit une attaque
par car kiff
pour essayer de prendre en tenace
mouvement de tonight que les riches
n'ont pas réussi à faire
il y a six mois est-ce qu'ils vont
retenter de le faire pour coincer la
majorité des troupes ukrainiennes qui
sont dans le domaine pour l'instant
franchement on n'en sait rien on a alors
les agents qui vous faut pas oublier qui
que dans quelques mois il y aura très
probablement une contre-offensive
Ukraine oui alors c'est ça aussi dont je
voulais parler c'est que en ce moment
voilà le conflit semble je l'ai depuis
un moment la raison à ça on a
l'impression que chaque armée se
renforce de son côté pour une future
offensive est-ce que la raison à ça est
pas forcément climatique aussi parce que
le terrain n'est pas favorable en ce
moment et le sera dans plusieurs mois
alors la météo compte et alors pour être
très précis en fait dans les
intersaisons
quand il pleut et quand il fait il y a
de la boue il y a la petite ça et
dans ces cas-là les blindés les chars
ne peuvent pas avancer et donc là c'est
à ce moment-là que pour des raisons
météorologiques le le conflit
se stabilise naturellement parce que les
les véhicules sont obligés de prendre
les routes qui sont pas toujours en bon
état et même les routes c'est compliqué
et donc ils peuvent pas sortir des
routes et donc la capacité de manœuvre
devient extrêmement faible quand il fait
très froid que le sol se gèle il peut y
avoir une reprise des combats parce
qu'il y a de nouveau enfin le seul le
seul n'est plus meuble et donc on peut
retrouver cette capacité de manœuvre
là l'hiver est plutôt relativement chaud
donc là
le gel est venu tardivement c'est pour
ça que malgré tout
en janvier février on peut pas exclure
malgré tout il y a cette capacité de
manœuvre théorique car le sol sera gelé
ensuite il y aura de nouveau une période
de de seul meuble où ça va être
compliqué et ensuite
il y aura de nouveau une capacité à
nommer mais vraiment de dire que l'hiver
il n'y a pas de manœuvre possible c'est
faux parce que le seul gelé
le printemps
alors on a pas mal de questions je vais
essayer de tous les prendre vous savez
mais on nous demande par exemple
savez-vous combien de combattants
français partis en Ukraine sont morts
depuis le début du conflit non on n'a
pas de ces chiffres là
alors j'en avais une tout à l'heure que
je ne retrouve plus oui on nous parle
alors Machiavel qui m’est pas une
question très précise il y avait des
informations sur les incendies et
incidents qui déclenchent en Russie
depuis le début de la guerre est-il
possible que ce soit des opérations
ukrainiennes effectivement il y en a
beaucoup sur des notamment dans des
souvent des des sites énergétiques oui
il est probable mais j'ai pas
d'informations précises là-dessus qu'il
y ait des opérations qui clandestine
on a des on a aussi des questions sur
les négociations je sais pas ce qu'on
parle un peu on a fini l'annoncer un
cesser le feu qui sont pas forcément
avoir de nouvelles qui n'a pas du tout
été
respecté puisque c'est à ce moment-là
que les alors il concernait peut-être
pas Wagner mais c'est à ce moment-là
l'offensive à soledar a vraiment
commencé à avancer donc
c'était surtout symbolique je pense à
destination de sa propre opinion
publique
est-ce que est-ce que on peut est-ce que
la porte des négociations et toujours
ouverte non là elle est clairement fermé
il y a un papier d'Isabelle Lasserre à
ce sujet dont le Figaro d'aujourd'hui
pourquoi parce que pour l'instant aucun
des deux pdgérants n'a intérêt il y a
une escalade militaire
conventionnelle mais des deux côtés et
donc pour l'instant aucun des deux
belligérant ni dans une position de
négocier c'est-à-dire que les Russes
[Musique]
pour l'instant n'ont pas d'intérêt à
s'arrêter là il y a pas eu
d'effondrement
du dispositif militaire rude dans le
don-basse qui aurait pu conduire pour le
coup
à des négociations donc les rues sont
encore des objectifs militaires on a vu
qu'il y a un flou sur lesquels sont ses
objectifs mais elle en a encore et elle
a encore une capacité
pour atteindre plus ou moins ces
objectifs puisque il y a les mobiliser
dont on a parlé donc du côté russe c'est
pas possible et du côté ukrainien c'est
absolument impossible non plus il y a
pas eu d'effondrement
ukrainiens et même au-delà de ça la
manière dont les Ukrainiens résistent
ont réussi leur contre-offensive pour
l'instant
c'est une victoire ukrainienne
indubitable cette guerre et pour
l'instant à ce jour c'est une une
défadreuse donc les Ukrainiens ont
évidemment encore des objectifs
militaires
savoir les objectifs politiques sont
clairs c'est reprendre l'intégralité de
l'Ukraine dans ses frontières
originel c'est-à-dire Crimée comprise
est-ce que l'Ukraine a les moyens
militaires et politiques de reprendre la
Crimée pour l'instant ça paraît
clairement un peu présumé de ses forces
mais entre la situation d'aujourd'hui et
la Crimée il y a plein de scénarios
intermédiaires notamment je pense qu'un
des scénarios principal c'est que vous
avez la région du Dombas à l'est vous
avez la Crimée un peu plus à l'ouest et
donc les Ukrainiens pourraient tenter
dans la région de la puridja c'est une
des hypothèses de couper les
territoire occupé russe en deux et ça ça
pourrait être une vraie défaite
stratégique pour pour la Russie car la
seule réussite d'un point de vue
stratégique pour Poutine aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il peut dire qu'il a réussi à
créer une continuité territoriale entre
la Crimée et le reste enfin et le
territoire russe une continental via
Paris Carson zapporigènes donc c'est
pour ça que Mario Paul était aussi
important pour le dossier important pour
lui le papier d'Isabelle Lasserre donc
parler tout à l'heure la guerre russe en
Ukraine a atteint un point de non-retour
on vous invite à lire forcément c'est
très intéressant
il y avait une autre question que je
voulais attendez je vais vous mettre la
carte un peu plus grand quand même là on
voit très bien c'est continuer
territoriale et donc on imagine aussi
cette possibilité d'une contre-offensive
ukrainienne qui couperait ses
territoires en deux on a zenken qui nous
dit le ministre de la Défense russe
vient d'annoncer la prise officielle de
de de de de Solidar que je viens de
effectivement c'est le cas l'armée russe
qui affirme avoir joué la conquête de la
ville de soleda dont on parlait je vais
vous montrer la carte de solida et
backgroute à côté qui sont ici c'est
quand zoomer sur le don-base n'hésitez
pas bien sûr à continuer à poser le
premier étage c'était Wagner maintenant
c'est le ministère russe de la Défense
maintenant c'est les animaux il faut
vérifier ce qu'il en est sur le sur le
terrain et puis voir aussi quelle est la
réaction
ukrainienne mais c'est si la ville était
prêt ça serait pas du tout une surprise
voilà
un arc non est-ce que la population
ukrainienne continue de soutenir la
guerre
ah oui il y a aucun doute là-dessus le
peuple ukrainien fait bloc
dernière son pays et des dernières
Zelenski il y a aucun doute là-dessus
donc là la volonté des Ukrainiens n'est
pas du tout affectée pour l'instant et
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles il
ne peut pas y avoir de négociation c'est
que le peuple crânien ne veut pas
négocierait pas alors et on avait aussi
des questions sur la mobilisation russe
déjà on a vu la mobilisation parce que
ça avait causé donc déjà côté est-ce
qu'il y aurait suffisamment de personnes
qui vous qui serait d'accord pour partir
et ensuite est-ce que les russes
auraient l'équipement suffisante pour
passer quand vous lier tout à l'heure de
500 000 à un peu moins d'un million je
me souviens il y a quelques mois qu'on
avait fait plusieurs live au début de la
mobilisation de l'annonce de la
mobilisation on avait vu des centaines
de milliers de Russes probablement 200
000 qui quittaient le pays
parce qu'il était contre la guerre parce
qu'il voulait pas être mobilisé et je
vous avais dit faites attention il n'y a
pas de ligne
d'une population russe qui qui
subitement
lâcherait
lâcherait le gouvernement russe Poutine
dans sa volonté de soutenir l'opération
militaire spéciale ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que ça fait donc
plusieurs elle est achevée
officiellement la mobilisation des
300000 hommes il y a eu des sondages de
levada qui est
une entreprise de sondage russe qui est
a priori fiable puisque même enfin le
Kremlin la considère comme une agence de
l'étranger donc ce qui est bon signe ce
qui est possible on peut considérer que
ce sont des sondages fiables et on
observe qu'il y a un soutien
tout à fait majoritaire actuelle de la
population russe
ça peut être un soutien
pour une partie très actif des
revendicatif ont vraiment de gens qui
veulent y aller
ça peut être aussi une forme de c'est
comme ça
plus plus mesuré mais en tout cas il n'y
a pas il n'y a pas de retournement de
l'opinion russe en tout cas pour
l'instant on ne le voit pas et il y a
certains chercheurs
ce fun qui qui étudie le pignon russe
et qui observe que la la propagande de
guerre russe et la propagande de guerre
ça existe toujours de tous les côtés
mais la propagande de guerre russe un
impact non négligeable quand la Russie
parle de guerre juste quand la Russie
considère qu'elle est dans une opération
finalement défensive ce qui peut
paraître paradoxal puisque c'est
évidemment la Russie qui envahit
l'Ukraine mais défensif par rapport à
une menace
au long cours de l'Occident etc et bien
ça a un impact certain sur l'opinion
russe et ça c'est une donnée vraiment à
prendre en compte pour 2023
c'est que pour l'instant il n'y a pas
de fragilisation extrême
du soutien russe à la guerre oui alors
il y a ça il y a aussi parce qu'on en
parle il y a beaucoup de rumeurs sur ce
sujet côté de de
Vladimir Poutine de l'état de santé de
routine est-ce que ça on sait que des
rumeurs à l'heure actuelle très
franchement pour l'instant on a rien on
préfère ne pas en parler c'est
maquillage quand aura lieu notre
prochain live on ne peut pas lui
répondre tout de suite vous savez nous
on fait des lives quand l'information
l'exige on va dire on va vous montrer
cette carte vous n'hésitez pas bien sûr
à continuer à poser vos questions
pas de souci il y a pas de souci
je continue de prendre vos questions
bien évidemment voilà je voulais parler
d'un article alors que je vais retrouver
dans quelques instants je vais pouvoir
vous montrer sur les grandes questions
2023 concernant le conflit on en a déjà
parlé de pas mal
de ces questions
mais est-ce que par exemple Poutine vont
survivre à 2023
aujourd'hui il y a rien qui indiquerait
que
Vladimir Poutine sont régime sur une
menacé
on n'est pas là du tout
je continue de regarder vous étiez pas
bien sûr à poser vos questions
alors on nous parle de Wagner et de
l'Afrique dans le dans les commentaires
ce n'est pas le sujet de ce live donc on
ne peut pas vous répondre sur cette
question la question la Crimée forcément
est centrale on a parlé tout à l'heure
la Crimée
c'est le plus c'est l'un des points
centrales de ce conflit la Russie ne
lâchera pas les Ukrainiens non plus on
sent que ça il y aura quand même avec ça
je suis d'accord mais militairement
c'est pas un objectif de court terme ou
même de moyen terme donc c'est une
question qui pourra se poser qui se pose
déjà mais on en est pas là encore
militairement
très bien et bien écoutez je pense qu'on
a fait le tour des questions qu'on avait
beaucoup Vincent merci beaucoup Alexis
merci à vous d'avoir été très nombreux à
nous suivre chriscount
ça nous fait très très plaisir vous
n'hésitez pas bien sûr abonnez-vous à
notre chaîne YouTube par exemple pour
les pour les pour les retrouver on va
vous les mettre tous en plus dans une
petite playlist pour les retrouver et on
vous dit à bientôt pour de nouveaux
lives votre prochain rendez-vous c'est
la question du jour à 17h30 à 17h avant
pardonnez-moi 17h le buzz TV 17h30 la
question du jour et 18h point de vue je
vous souhaite une bonne journée sur le
Figaro live et à bientôt